okay today I'm going to talk to you
about the electromagnetic spectrum
now this strange image is just to try
and help you remember the different
parts of the electromagnetic spectrum
red monsters invading us using x-ray
goggles if you can remember this then it
helps you to remember the order of the
different parts of the spectrum radio
waves microwaves infrared visible light
ultraviolet x-rays and gamma rays so
let's see what that actually means now
what the electromagnetic spectrum
actually is is it's just these different
waves that have a different frequency
so at one end remember red monsters at
one end we have radio waves so these
ones have the longest wavelength
remember wavelengths just a distance
between either two peaks or two troughs
of a way and it so it has the longest
wavelength and it also has the lowest
frequency so frequency is how many waves
pass the point in one second and it's
measured in hertz so the further we go
this way because the waves are closer
and closer together we can see that they
get a higher and higher frequency so
let's remember red monsters invade Venus
using x-ray goggles so what they stand
for is radio waves microwaves infrared
visible light ultraviolet x-rays and
gamma so at this end we have longest
wavelength so therefore our gamma they
have the shortest wavelength this is the
lowest frequency our gamma
up here has the highest frequency
so all of these different waves are
passing through our atmosphere can be
used for different things the only one
that we could see is visible light now
visible light is split up into different
sections as well the longest wavelength
in visible light is red so we've got
something to remember hopefully you
learnt this at Primary School the colors
in a rainbow Richard of York gave gave
battle and I'm apologize I haven't got a
different pen for indigo and violet gave
battle in vain red orange yellow blue
acai green blue indigo violet so this
means red is the part of the visible
light spectrum that has the longest
wavelength violet is the part that has
the shortest wavelength so all of these
different colors appear different due to
their different wavelengths now this
makes sense if you can't remember which
way round it goes
just remember that red goes next to
infra red and violet goes next to ultra
violet because all that we're saying is
if we go a little bit further that way a
slightly longer wavelength we can no
longer see it but that's where infra red
is similarly if we have a slightly
higher frequency than violet we can no
longer see it but that wave is still
there it's called ultra violet so those
are essentially the different that's the
basic overview of the electromagnetic
spectrum based on wavelength and
frequency the different parts of the
spectrum including the different parts
of the visible light spectrum and this
technique that should hopefully help you
remember red monsters invading us using
x-ray goggles radio waves microwaves
infrared visible light ultraviolet
x-rays gamma thank you